تخشى علامات تجاريه في شوارع التسوق
الاوروبيه من مثل هؤلاء
المستهلكين يحولون قراراتهم الفرديه
بمقاطعه شركات بعينها لوائها مع اسرائيل
الى حركه جماعيه تغير في سلوك المستهلكين
رافق الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه لا تعلن
الشركات خسائرها خشيه تاثر قيمتها السوقيه
وفق مختصين لكن بعض الاثر لا يمكن اخفاؤه
فسلس مطاعم ماكدونالدز شهدت خلو بعض
فروعها من الزبائن خاصه في دول عربيه
ومسلمه حيث سجل في بعضها انخفاض المبيعات
بنسبه 70% على الاقل خلال شهري اكتوبر
ونوفمبر وهو الامر الذي اشار اليه كريس
كمبنسكي المدير التنفيذي لماكدونالدز حيث
قال ان اسواق متعدده في في الشرق الاوسط
واخرى خارجه تتعرض لاثر اقتصادي ملموس
بسبب الحرب والمعلومات المضلله المرافقه
لها ستاربكس كانت هي الاخرى ضمن الشركات
المستهدف انخفضت القيمه السوقيه لاسهمها
بنحو 11 مليار دولار لاسباب ابرزها
المقاطع ما ادى الى تقليص قواها العامله
او حتى اغلاق بعضها تماما زار للالبسه
مثال اخر تسببت حمله اعلانيه لها بغضب قاد
الى اغلاق بعض متاجرها في بريطانيا
[تصفيق]
مؤقتا لم اشتري بضائع اسرائيليه منذ عقود
كنت عميلا لدى بنك باركليز الذي يستثمر في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ويقرض ومنذ عام ونصف
اتظاهر مع اخرين امام فرعه في منطقتنا
لوقف
ذلك
اصبحت اكثر وعيا بكيفيه استهلاكي وما اذا
كنت بحاجه الى اشياء بعينها فقد اعتدت
شراء الكثير من ماكدونالدز وقد وضعت هذه
العاده الان
جانبا تحقق المقاطعه انجازات لكنها تواجه
تحديات متجدده فحكت غربيه كالولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا تسعى الى
منعها اسرائيل خصصت الكثير من الجهد
لشيطنة المقاطعه ومحاوله اقناع الحكومات
الاجنبيه بسن تشريعات تقمع حق المواطنين
في دعم المقاطعه وسحب الاستثمارات وفرض
العقوبات على
[تصفيق]
اسرائيل يؤمن هؤلاء النشطون بجدول مقاطع
فهي بغض النظر عن اثرها الاقتصادي تمثل
ادانه لاسرائيل في محكمه الراي العام
العالمي كما يرون لكن المقاطعه ليست سوى
وجه واحد للحركه ضنيه مع الحقوق
الفلسطينيه التي تحولت الى احدى اكبر
الحملات السياسيه المستمره في التاريخ
البريطاني ظلت لندن في طليعه الاحتجاجات
العالميه الغربيه فمئات الالاف من
المتظاهرين كانوا ينزلون الى الشوارع
نهايه كل اسبوع للمطالبه بوقف اطلاق
النار حشود ظلت تزيد ولا تنقص مع مضي
اسرائيل في حربها على غزه رغم عداء
الحكومات وعدم مبالاه احزاب المعارضه
الكبرى في معظم دول اوروبا حركه تضامنيه
عالميه تجاوزت الاديان والاعراق والثقافات
والجنسيات ووحدها ايمان جماعي بالحق
الفلسطيني محمد المدهون الجزيره
لندن